is it just a he-said she-said is it
really that simple and why is this now
in the hands of the FBI why because the
establishment Republicans have buckled
caved and bowed to the Democrats or
should I say demon rats that's what I
said
demon rats spectacled I saw this week
was one of the most pathetic
disheartening saddest displays to which
to this nation has ever stood witness it
was for all intents and purposes a
crucifixion of a man who has led the
kind of exemplary life few of us can
mirror now you already know I was a
felony court judge you know I've been
both a prosecutor and then the DA sex
crimes and crimes against women and
children were my crusade
I assess whether cases should go forward
whether the accused should be charged
convicted and if so as a judge what the
sentence should be no one sympathizes
more than I when it comes to women who
are the silent victims of crime I
created the first domestic violence unit
in the nation which was the Department
of Justice pilot program
Christine Blasi Ford is a lovely lady
who is credible and I believe something
happened to her but she's in over her
head and she is being used no matter how
many indelible Hippo Camus brain
comparisons she made she couldn't
remember the fundamentals whose house it
was where it was when the party was how
she got to the house or how she got home
she waits 36 years not telling her
mother a friend a high school counselor
or anyone before now if Ford said no one
was there that it was just she and
Cavanaugh or it was just he and she
alone in a parking lot then it's a true
he said she said but once she chose to
say there were four people there
it's they said yet all four of they said
nothing happened they weren't there they
don't know what she's talking about
now what does that tell you about Ford's
memory if they weren't there
is it possible Cavanaugh wasn't there
either
now crucial here is Ford's therapy visit
in 2012 for the first time in three
decades she says she mentions
Cavanaugh's name if true why was the
name Cavanaugh not in the therapists
notes and why would Ford's lawyers
withhold those therapists notes at least
the part that referred to this alleged
event why was Ford so evasive one
question by the prosecutor on this issue
why did her attorneys interfere with her
answering in her testimony on this point
were methods used to help her recall
whatever traumatic event occurred if a
rape victim undergoes hypnosis sometime
prior to testimony for the purpose of
refreshing her memory of the incident
the court and jury is entitled to know
because of the risk of confabulation of
recent events like television newspapers
that impact one's memory it is not a
reliable means of refreshing one's
recollection Ford's attorneys even said
she was afraid to fly and had to drive
across the country yet we now know she
was never told the committee was willing
to come to her we find out she's not
afraid to fly the woman's flown all over
the country and the world the South
Pacific in Hawaii but move all of that
out of the way what we're really dealing
with here is hypocrisy not who's right
and wrong who's guilty who's innocent
this is about people desperate to win at
all costs take a man and his family down
no problem it's the Battle of the
hypocrite
now Jeff Flake is the perfect example he
says after the hearing he's going to
vote for Cavanaugh but the man buckles
after two women scream at him while
preventing his elevator door from
closing what happened to me doesn't
matter of course it matters but what
does your abuse have to do with Brett
Kavanaugh hundreds of thousands of women
have been abused in this country take
your anger out on the person who abused
you go to court convict him send him to
jail spit on him I don't care but don't
you dare blame Brett Kavanaugh for your
victimization only wimp Jeff Flake is
dumb enough weak enough to not even get
it and Cory Booker the wannabe Spartacus
he has the gall to stand up and
criticize a man who is literally an
altar boy on the politics of sexual
assault
the ultimate hypocrite Booker admits
roping another young woman when he was
15 why aren't we going after him and
that genius Senator mazie Hirono who
allegedly graduated from high school
either skipped the presumption of
innocence class or she's willing to
throw it all away for her political gain
and maisy your hypocrisy knows no bounds
when you have the nerve to say the
Republicans the Republicans have tossed
out the rules you're the one who
declared Cavanaugh guilty before hearing
any testimony simply because it was a
woman who was the accuser and all you
men shut up and you're willing to openly
say conservatives are simply not
entitled to the presumption of innocence
who are you but my favorite Diane
Feinstein madam you don't deserve to be
in the United States Senate and no one
can believe anything you have to say
each of these allegations should be
investigated by the FBI two days ago you
called for an FBI investigation what a
shock why didn't you ask for it in July
when you got the Ford letter you didn't
ask for it because you're a hypocrite no
like a Cheshire Cat you sat on it to
inflict the most damage at the most
damaging time possible
Ford Christine Ford didn't want to be
exposed but no you had other plans your
plan was to leak it
you actually gave Ford the name of a
democratic and Democrat Attorney poor
dr. Ford this woman doesn't know she was
nothing more than a puppet on the string
of democratic politics
Diane where's your integrity you and
everyone in the Senate knows how this
should have been handled confidentially
the FBI should have been involved before
it's how it's done no one has any
respect for you but in the end Lindsey
Graham said it best there is no way to
investigate something that happened 35
years ago when you can't tell them the
month the location so this is not about
getting to the truth and that's the
opening statement if you like my opening
statements you'll love my new book New
York Times the Rhoyne bestseller liars
Deacons and liberals which I shamelessly
try to advance on this show